hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2021 tata steel chess
tournament
the last game we'll be showing as i
already mentioned yesterday there was
um a lot of controversy during the
actual game so we're going to discuss
that a little bit as well uh it's
versus serratus and as the situation
currently stands alireza is still hoping
that he will
beat radoslav this game and uh maybe go
into tie breaks against uh whoever
comes out on top where it will be fabian
nigerie um
the the now known winner of the tata
steel uh jordan land forest or whoever
uh so all the reason uh needs to play a
great game and
let's see what happened here and also i
have one very interesting announcement
at the end of the video
uh so stay tuned for that as well so
alireza with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 uh we have d5 by
radic we have
g3 and now knight to d7 going for the
king's indian attack with white we have
d4 uh and
now knight to b6 this is the so-called
baxter system
and it's uh well it's a very uh sneaky
way to play with black
we have knights to c3 and not knight to
f6 so
the four knights are outside but this
knight is a little bit to the left
i know this triggers a lot of you but uh
chess is sometimes
ruthless like that so here a4
immediately alireza wants to kick away
this knife from b6
so a5 preventing that and now bishop to
g2 alireza continues developing
h6 and castles and here bishop to f5
and the just that uh uh you know uh
get you ready for it this will be a very
very complicated game with very very
you know tricky lines so knights the h4
going after the bishop bishop to h7 and
now the immediate f4 already alireza
wants to play f5 close off uh the light
square bishop and
kind of make it problematic for black to
play e6
so avoid the chicken goes e6 right away
and f5 now alexa wants to
capture on e6 and get a nice semi-open
file for his rook
uh and here bishop to e7 uh here if you
capture it there is just
nothing good to come of it if captures
captures and captures
white's uh white setup is just great
he's going to develop the queen for
example
bishop to e7 e4 and after captures and
captures
you can castle but then let's say c3 a
white will get the queen into the game
the bishop then play rook 8
f1 have already rooks doubled on the f
file and
white will have a great game so instead
after f5 we have bishop to e7 by
voitershek and now
bishop to h3 mounting more pressure on
that e6 pawn
queen to d7 defending and now queen to
d3
also adding another defender to the f5
pawn queen to c6 now
and here comes knight to b5 and here
alireza wants to bring his bishop to f4
and go after that c7 pawn so here
knight to c4 first kind of saying that
maybe
you cannot play bishop to f4 but of
course alireza can do it
this is never actually a problem so
bishop to f4
and now of course you cannot go after
the pawn even though it attacks the
queen because
just queen to b3 and then the knight has
to move and then you capture on c7
knight c4
knight captures here and it's just game
over for black so instead after bishop
f4 we have knight to d6
and now comes queen to e3 i would just
like to uh
i would just like to mention that
instead of this queen to e3 idea
uh you could go for some captures on d6
but
as you know usually if you don't really
gain anything you you do not play moves
like that
so queen to e3 uh aligning the queen
nicely with the king here and also you
have to be very careful here because
you can never castle queen side at least
not while the knight is here
uh for example if castles knight to a7
check just picks up the queen
so here we have knight the c4 again
challenging the queen
queen back to d3 and now bishop the d6
so reuters offers a trade of bishops and
here we have
knight captures on d6 oh it is a trace
this night for bishop
uh it's very interesting uh alireza had
a very uh
interesting move here that i'm gonna
mention but it's uh
it's a move you simply don't even
consider it's something
uh the great misha would maybe consider
bishop captures on h6 g
captures and now b3 trying to kick away
the knight and now black has to figure
out
that okay my only square is b6 even
though b6 is a terrible square for the
knight
he would have to give the knight back
with knight to e5 but just to show you
if knight to b6 queen to e3 and uh
white's position is just
great uh regardless of uh white being
down a pawn he has a beautiful bishop
here
queen excellently plays the knight is a
monster uh you're ready to open up the f
file to bring the other rook into the
game
and like we already mentioned black will
struggle to find a good move here
because castles is never an option
because of this
check losing the queen so it was um
bishop captures an h6 is a very
complicated idea but
uh for alireza goes for knight captures
on d6
uh this comes with check we have knight
captures on d6 and now
bishop to e5 just improving the position
of that bishop
and then now comes knight d to e4 black
also wants to have a nice
outpost for the knights we have queen to
a3 now preparing
uh preventing the kingside castle and
now queen to d7
here uh voyager wants to play c6 even
though
here castle in queenside is always an
option but it it looks very scary white
can just start pushing those pawns
uh get the rooks behind the pawns and uh
well
it just doesn't feel all that pleasant
but okay queen to d7 was played and
now c4 so alireza wants to open up
lines now as uh the black king is
probably going queen side but it's still
very early to tell
so c6 and now f captures on e6 with f
captures on e6 and c captures on d5 with
knight captures on the e5
and now bishop to g2 so what you play
here
knights to d2 but rather going after
that rook and if you're not careful
knights the c4 is coming with an attack
on the bishop and the queen
so here uh rook f the c1 maybe maybe a
slight improvement is bishop to f3 but
this is such a
such a crazy engine move that you it it
seems
weird to even consider this now of
course uh capturing the rook is out of
the question because of bishop to h5 but
then after castle's queen side you could
maybe then shift the rook to c1 so maybe
the bishop is better on f3 than on g2
but uh you know
who are we to know such things so here
knight to d2 and
rook f to c1 as planned we have rook to
f8
and now comes knight back to f3 so here
knight captures on f3 and bishop
captures on f3 so as you can see bishop
finds its way to f3 that either way
and now not going for a queen side
castle because that would be too
dangerous
king the f7 going for a nice artificial
castling with king f7 king g8
uh and now finally e4 grabbing hold of
the center and kicking away the knight
from d5 with knight to b4 and
now queen to e3 uh we have king the g8
to the king now is
safely tucked in on g8 and now rook to
c3
uh the rooks can now be doubled up on
the c file and maybe alireza can make
something of this we have rook
8 to d8 and now comes h4
uh we have b6 by black and now bishop to
e2 shifting the bishop over to this
diagonal
we have queen to e7 and now bishop back
to g4 now
putting pressure on the e6 pawn so here
queen to f7
uh but queen to f7 is not really a
problem for white because
black is playing a waiting game here
here voyager is waiting for
uh alireza to decide what he wants to do
do the rooks belong on the c file and
the f file does he want to play d5 at
some point
he's just testing him and here uh h5
just grabbing more space the bishops are
excellently placed here because they
cover
all of these uh squares and you really
don't have to worry about
that queen rook battery there so h5
grabbing more space here not allowing
any g6 ideas in the future we have queen
back to e7 again uh black just waits to
see what
white will do and now rook a to c1 and
here alireza says
um i might be interested in grabbing
this as
i'm attacking the e6 pawn so it could be
uh could
it could be that something good comes of
it that even though it will come with
with the price of an exchange and here
uh if you go for this knight to a2 which
alireza is allowing with the double
attack on the rooks you would get
exactly that rook captures on c6
and after you capture on c1 first a nice
fission two
bishop captures on e6 with check king h8
and only now you recapture the knight
here
and you get to this um well really weird
position where
white has this amazing center uh ready
to pick up more points on the queen set
and the e4 pawn is off limits if you
capture on e4
then of course queen captures on h6 is
coming and that's just it bishop to h7
and now rook to c7 and it's the game
over the queen moves and you're getting
checkmated or you have to give up the
queen
and then you're getting checkmated so
after rocate the c1
uh radix said uh all right that seems to
be like too much i'm just gonna play
queen to e8 uh defend this pawn one more
time
but now he allows it bishop to c7 and
now
uh alireza will grab a pawn but he will
still lose the exchange so rook d7 we
have bishop captures on b6
and now finally knight to a2 going after
the rooks here
rook captures on c6 and now knight
captures on c1
we have rook captures on c1 and now rook
to b7
attacking the bishop here and bishop to
c5 so everything is nicely defended you
cannot grab the pawn because the rook is
hanging
so rook f2 f7 and now b3 and everything
is now nicely cemented this bishop is
coming to c4 to
keep an eye on the b3 pawn and
regardless of black having the two rooks
the bishop
pair will be will be uh well
maybe almost fully operational so let's
see what happens we have rook f the c7
and rook back to e1 uh rook to c6
and now bishop to e2 preparing to shift
the bishop over to c4 we have queen to
b8
and now comes uh bishop to b5 first
first pushing back the rook rook to c8
and now bishop back to c4
and now white's king is a little bit
loose here so you have to be careful
that queen is eyeing the g3 pawn
if black somehow gets one check and then
yeah you can
you know kiss your winning chances
goodbye so here came the h8
on pinning and now comes rook to f1
so what do you play here we have bishop
to g8
uh adding more more defense to the d5
square and now comes king to g2 so the
g3 pawn is nicely defended
uh rook to d7 and now rook to f2
uh so uh adding adding more defense to
that white king we have queen to b7
now aligning the queen with the king
here and now rook to e2
uh we have queen back to c7 and now
bishop to a3
uh just preparing to shift the bishop
over to this diagonal
uh we have queen to b6 now uh preventing
white from going d5 as the queen
queens would get traded off so bishop to
b2 first defending the pawn one more
time
and now bishop back to h7 and here
alireza played queen to f4
uh and now uh you don't have to worry
about
queen being on e3 so bishop back to g8
keeping an eye on the d5 square and
this is where things could have gone
extremely well for alireza
uh but they are both very low on time
and they still have to make
uh six more eight more moves until they
reach the second
time control so here alireza played
queen to g4 however i will just mention
d5 here is just is just great it seems
like it's impossible because this is
defended
twice but for example captures captures
and now you don't have to worry about
bishop captures because the tactics work
in uh
the tactics work in white's favor for
example bishop captures on d5
rook captures and now bishop captures on
g7
king captures and queen to g for check
picks up the rook
now while this is something that alireza
sees probably in the blink of an eye the
problem
i think he didn't go for d5 because
after d5 you could go for captures
captures and then not captures but
rather queen to d6 so you could kind of
prevent
uh all the exchanges and even the white
is still better here
uh al alireza cannot allow even uh
a chance for uh for uh reutershire to
save the game because he needs that
winter
uh you know catch up to giri and the
others so here after bishop the g8 we
have queen g4
now putting a lot of pressure on black's
king here and now
rook c the d8 uh we have bishop to c3
and now comes a move that is really
really tricky
queen to c6 here rather gives up the a5
pawn voluntarily
uh for some uh for some counter play or
maybe it was even uh
even even a blunder but i don't think it
was uh i think he actually uh
wanted to give it away so here bishop
captures on a5 and now
rook back to b8 we have queen to f4
now attacking the rook there and rook d
to b7
and now black is ready to give up those
rooks for
for the bishop and the pawn point being
that if you play
bishop back to c3 then black happily
picks up the pawn here captures captures
and captures the bishop is under attack
let's say bishop b2
and now the game continues but black
will very easily collect
the rest of the pawns and you've given
back the material but you've taken care
of all of the threats on the queen side
so alireza doesn't allow that he goes
queen to e3
adds more support to the b3 pawn and now
queen
back to e8 attacks the h5 point l it is
a defensive with the g4
and now queen to d7 and here
uh there are some ideas of playing king
to h3
uh for the moment improving the position
of your king but alireza goes for the
immediate the
queen to g3 so what do you play here
here alireza is giving up
the d4 pawn in order to play bishop the
c3 with
tempo and radik after considering the
position for a while
decides to capture it they are both
extremely low on time and this is the
move 58 so two more moves until time
control
bishop to c3 and now as the queen is
under attack
queen to d1 and uh they both need to
make one more move to reach time control
and here alireza played rook to eat rook
to d2
he reached the second time control and
this is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine
uh and it was at this point that alireza
left the the playing table and he went
on
to see what was happening uh with the
tournament and uh
i think it was at this point that he saw
that he no longer has a
chances of getting into tie breaks
because uh
ivan forest has better additional
criteria than him
and uh even if he wins the game both him
and geary would have better additional
criteria and it would definitely be a
match between the two of them and
alireza would not even get a chance to
compete
so here i can imagine that he was very
very sad when he saw this but
then his problems only started then
because i mean that kind of
ruins your entire tournament uh because
we all know alireza came here to win it
and to show everyone that he's the best
uh but
um after learning uh learning this uh
i'm sure he didn't even feel like
playing the game anymore but the problem
was that his position is still much
better
but here they they started interrupting
him constantly and
they were walking around the plane hole
making everything uh
uh ready for the tie breaks between
anishigiri and the jordan one forest
and alireza was of course very annoyed
by this he was uh
you know uh telling them to back off to
you know be quiet he's still playing the
game
and then they even interrupted the game
at some point to tell them that they
should move in another room to continue
playing the game there but that's just
um that's just something you don't
do i mean i i know when i was playing in
tournaments and i'm uh
i'm nowhere near in the playing strength
of the these guys but it doesn't matter
when you're playing your own game and
when you're
in the game for five hours they were
playing over six hours uh
and someone interrupts you it just
completely shatters your your
concentration
and uh it's something that's uh very
interesting because
i i seriously doubted that they would do
something like this if it was magnus
still playing or let alone imagine if
they did this
to gary kasparov i mean uh there are
videos on youtube where
people just walk uh to look at
kasparov's position and he gives them
such a death stare
i mean it's an instant kill stare so
interrupting
kasparov in a position like this would
be i i i don't think they would
you know lift the tail to tell the tale
uh but alireza is only 17 and
i guess they figured that yeah it's it's
okay to pick on this kid
but i it was a very very poorly done
because it's not only the
uh the final standings of the tournament
that matter here but alireza is also
knocking on doors of being
in the world top 10 in classical so
interrupting him here that's
that's just something you don't do but
okay
it happened wha what can you do after
all it is rook to d2 queen to b1 was
played eradic also reaches time control
and now here you have to find you have
to find the move here
uh and uh the the best for white here is
now queen to d3 and white has to opt for
for an end game but i think alireza was
already very very annoyed here and that
he
simply couldn't concentrate to take this
game into an end game for example
captures captures
and now black would have this freeing e5
move going for bishop captures to
eliminate the defenders of the b3 pawn
we would see captures captures and now
b4 and white still has the two connected
pass pawns here
that are defended and it would be a very
very
uh well tricky position to play but
white is better and alireza can still
push
however after queen to b1 alireza played
queen to f4
rather quickly and it seemed like
there's no defense i mean everything is
hanging this is hanging
the bishops are just amazing here how do
you stop this but
there is one move that saves the radix
so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this uh saving move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
incredible
uh e5 also for those who just want to
enjoy the show because this is a
such a not an easy move to find but it
does make sense because now
uh there is no queen captures on h6
because the bishop is blocked so you
have to react to this but also
your bishop is under attack on c4 so
what do you do here
problem is if you go queen captures an
e5 you're not really threatening
anything black will just capture on c4
and after b
captures uh let's say rook rook of faith
threaten queen to f1 and you don't have
any threats this is defended by the rook
on b7
so here aleris said okay i'm just gonna
grab this and i still have this
thread so what do you do but voitershek
said uh i'm just gonna play bishop
captures on c4
it's not a problem you don't have any
threats here if you capture here
i'm just gonna play king g8 and now your
queen is hanging you have to move the
queen and i'm just going to play rook g8
again with
the same threats and black is just the
winning here
so alireza after this b captures a
bishop captures on c4
decided to play b captures on c4 and
it was in this position almost 63 that
they agreed to a draw
as now there is really nothing more for
white to do here
uh capturing an h6 is pointless uh and
it just wouldn't really make sense i
will however however mention what
happens if you captured the rook because
that was also one of the options
still just rook to f7 again black grabs
hold of this
f1 square and not much you can do here
if queen to e3
even a bishop captures on b3 you you can
even grab that pawn to completely
eliminate white
white's counter play and you would very
much enjoy playing this but here all it
is just played b
captures on c4 and it was in this
position that they agreed to a draw
because even if the game continues uh
you would see something like rook to e8
and you don't really care if queen
captures an h6 check king j8
white doesn't have a good continuation
here if queen to g6 is preparing h6
just rook to f7 the rook is also under
attack so rook f7
and now h6 here challenging uh this this
pawn
uh but it's not a problem just queen f1
check and now it's it's just a draw
king h2 rook f2 check captures captures
with check
and now black either continues checking
you or you go up the board
queen e3 check king h4 and then just uh
continue with queen to h1 check
or if you go queen to e3 here which is
even better to connect with the pawn
here now you either push the white king
back
or if white insists just queen captures
on h4 you trade queens and now this is
uh this is drawn
bishop f4 let's say king h7 defends the
pawn e5 but you will collect all of
these pawns and it's not a problem
so after the big captures on c4 uh
the game ended and what what a fight it
was uh but
this is uh just what i wanted to say uh
alireza was
better uh for the entire game and he had
a lot of
moments where he could have played
better but
i mean it's just unimaginable
interrupting uh
i mean he he's uh he's uh almost a top
ten player in the world
you cannot interrupt him in the final
round of a classical tournament
that's that's something you don't do i
mean that's that's
unheard of uh i mean uh
like i have no no better better example
but imagine if they did this
the magnus or caspar it would be i mean
i don't know
so uh very poorly handled by the
organizers but
i guess i guess they uh the players
signed off on this uh before the
tournament even started that if such an
uh such a situation occurs then they
would act
this way but even if that's the case i
don't think it
justifies how they handle it so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and like i said uh i will uh
i i do have some news as uh well as the
channel is uh
nearing the mark of 1 million
subscribers i decided
i decided to start a second channel
where i will be helping
any of you whoever wishes to make video
content
of course regarding chess you will be
able to contact me and i will be using
this other channel to promote
other chess channels so if you are
interested in that i will
talk a little bit more about this
because there was this was a long video
i don't want to
spend too much talking about it now but
basically i will put a link to the
channel in the description below and
also in email
where you can contact me and uh you know
ask any questions if you're interested
and also
maybe send a a a at least a little bit
some of the video material that you are
uh either currently producing or you are
preparing
if you are maybe interested in starting
a youtube channel
so uh the the the reason i'm doing this
is that
uh well i i've already grown uh to too
big
and i would like to use this you know
power for for some good
so if i can help you guys start your own
channels and
also help uh everyone else who enjoys
chess to even find you because
you might be creating awesome content
and people just can't find you
uh in this uh well huge sea of youtube
channels so
that was kind of my idea here so feel
free to contact me the email is in the
description below and also the link to
that
channel is in the is in the description
below there's still nothing on it
so there's no point subscribing to it
now because uh
there's still nothing on it i will
inform you guys when uh
when we will start uh producing content
there so you can also check that out and
uh you know uh discover other content
creators who are
who are just maybe starting out but
maybe have awesome content maybe it's
not gonna be
chess analysis maybe it's gonna be chess
lore maybe it's going to be
chess history maybe it's going to be uh
i don't know uh
it could be anything fun related uh you
know
like literally anything so just wanted
to get that out there
uh just to know that that's something
that's definitely happening
uh but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it
uh
better luck uh to alireza in the next
one but uh as we've seen from miss
playing this tournament uh
it's i i think it's uh fair to assume
that alireza is definitely the future
so i hope you guys enjoyed it once again
i would like to thank
mr uh sb arie eisenbach stefan heber
and bradley peterson for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the
uh coverage of the morphe saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day